[Music]
how you use your voice is really
important and it's really driven by
context more than anything else so if
you and your tonal voice will
immediately begin to impact somebody's
mood and then at this immediately how
their brain function says it's actually
scientific data and that out there now
that shows us that our brains will work
up to 31% more effectively if we're in a
good mood so if I smile at you and you
see it or you can hear a smile in
someone's voice if I automatically smile
it at you and you can hear that I like
you I will actually be able to reach
into your brain flip the positive switch
put you in a better mood they're mirror
neurons in our brain that we have no
control over they automatically respond
and if I intentionally put you in a good
mood your brain will be working more
effectively and that already begins to
increase the chances that you're going
to collaborate me with me you'll be
smarter and you like me more at the same
time now upward and downward inflection
downward inflection is often used to say
you know this is the way it is there's
no other way and I will say it exactly
like that if there's a term in a
contract that there's no movement on and
I want you to know it and feel it
without me having to say there's no
movement on this which you know maybe
you want to yell at somebody and that
that's ineffective because that triggers
a different part of the brain and makes
people angry and they want to fight and
I've done this in contract negotiations
I've said things like we don't do work
for hire just like that well that's the
other side no there's no movement
whatsoever I also may need to put you in
a more collaborative frame of mind and
if I want to if I want to ask you a
question I'll say something like it
seems like this is important to you and
I'll fluffed up it's more driven by
context and I can use a upward
inflection to encourage you and smile
while I'm questioning you and that'll
make you feel less attacked
by being questioned because people are
made to feel a little bit defensive when
they're questioned anyway so if I know
if I have to question you if I want you
to think about a different option that
I'm going to be as encouraging as
possible while I may be very assertive
at the same time the mirroring that I
teach is not the same as the way most
people think of marring most people when
they think of marrying they think
mirroring body language mirroring tone
of voice even using the same words it's
not that at all the mirroring that I
teach is much more simplistic and
interestingly enough has a great impact
on how the other person interacts with
you and it's just repeating the last one
two three words that they've said word
for word one two three words or it's
repeating a selected one two three words
and what it really does is it helps
connect people's thoughts there will
almost never be a time when you mirrored
the last three words of what someone
said when they want to go on and explain
and reward and expand and that mirror
what it's just done is it helped give
you a better understanding what the
other person is trying to say it also
gives you more time to think it's a way
to buy time and a negotiation for
yourself the other person doesn't see
you buying time in any way shape or form
it's a great way when you don't know
what to say where to go to keep them
talking in a way that they're very
comfortable with one of my clients
actually mirrors his counterparts
positions every single time every time
they stated make a statement on a
position he simply mirrors it they'll
repeat it they'll expand it and every
time he does that it also gives them a
good feel for whether or not they're
really stable in that position or
whether there's quite a bit of softness
in a position completely based on how
they reward and respond to his mirror so
Mir is a great way to keep somebody else
talking very comfortably the f-word in
negotiations is fair fair is the
f-bomb and and when you begin to look
for it it's stunning and how many
negotiations somebody drops the f-bomb
in the negotiation and when somebody
says we just want what's fair that's
actually a really bad sign one of two
things is going on now the cutthroat
negotiators know how much I can punch
your buttons if I say I've given you a
fair offer and that will immediately put
you on the defensive and make you worry
about whether or not you're being fair
and most people have an instinctive
feeling about fair price fair market
fair is just like this incredibly
overused term in negotiations I just
want what's fair what's the fair market
price so if I say I've given you a fair
offer and I'm using you being unfair
I've immediately knocked you back on
your heels it's a way for me to gain an
advantage on you if I'm that kind of a
negotiator the flip side of it is maybe
I've been assertive enough in the
negotiations and I haven't been using
enough tactical empathy that the other
person feels like I'm taking taking
taking from them and they'll respond
with I just want what's fair that maybe
someone genuinely telling me very
indirectly that they feel I've been far
too aggressive and if they feel I've
been aggressive and if they feel treated
unfairly one of two things is going to
happen they're either going to walk away
from a great deal or they're going to
make implementation painful when
implementation of a negotiation is
painful when they drag their feet when
they don't make deadlines when they
don't deliver the product quality
they're supposed to deliver when they're
not as thorough and paying as much
attention to detail because they didn't
feel it was a fair deal that destroy
your profit so you have to really keep
an eye out for the f-bomb in
negotiations and when somebody else
feels they've been treated unfairly
they're probably going to hurt you over
[Music]